combien de temps ça va durer je ne sais
pas peut-être 12 heures ou moins gens
c'est bien il faut que j'ai créé ce qui
fait vibrer un bon coup d'annuaires ça
peut le faire vibrer non non moment pour
nombre de raisons non il faut vous armer
de patience d'accord il est crucial
crucial que vous demeuriez patiente
il est aussi crucial que vous enleviez
disparaît n'avaient non elle va poser un
problème barrette il vous qu'avez-vous
sur la tête way sur le sommet de la tête
au moins c'est pas bizarre mais comme
différent mais bon on y va bon avant
d'entrer dans cette pièce n'oubliez pas
que nous avons créé un lien aujourd'hui
je vous supplie de me faire confiance
êtes vous consciente de l'importance que
ça ouais j'en suis consciente
aurez vous un peu de patience j'en
aurais entendu je vous crois bonjour
café j'adore le café sans doute même un
peu trop